welcome everybody want to go through a
couple of clips i spotted over the last
week
bookmarked them didn't end up having
time to talk about these
um earlier in the week first one is of
everybody's best friend
former judge yeah and republican
congressman louis gomert
who i just don't know how this guy
manages to get himself to work every day
with the things he seems to believe and
be confused by
during a recent hearing um
congressman louis gomer asked
whether the bureau of land management
might be able to change the orbit
of the moon in order to deal with
climate change
uh once and for all um
let's take a look at this now the
premise is that the moon's orbit is
changing and that's true we know that
that's an absolutely true thing the moon
is slowly drifting away from earth
um at something like a 3.8 centimeters
per year
and that's something we've seen over the
last you know
couple few billion years or so and
um louie's idea is maybe
the forest management and bureau of land
management agencies
they could just change the moon's orbit
even further okay here's the uh
here's the clip and check out the
reaction from us jennifer silberstein
it's just perfect and i understand from
what's been testified to the forest
service and the
blm you want very much to
work on the issue of climate change i
was uh
informed by the media past director of
nasa that they have found that
the moon's orbit is changing slightly
and so is the earth's orbit around the
sun
we know there's been uh significant
solar flare
activity um and so
is there anything that the national
forest service
or blm can do to
change the course of the moon's orbit
or the earth's orbit around the sun
obviously that would have profound
effects
on our climate
i would have to follow up with you on
that one mr gohmert
yeah well if you figure out a way that
you
in the uh forest service can make that
change
i'd like to know uh also just to uh
put on your radar that reaction is is
just
something else it's sort of you know
when
a kid says i want to make a dinosaur and
you say
yeah let's check that out uh jimmy
let's let's look into that that sounds
interesting this is
painfully dumb and this this is up there
like with
donald trump wanting to nuke a hurricane
or something like that like how do we
even
analyze this other than to say is
it scarier that this guy's currently a
member of congress
or is it scarier that this guy used to
be a judge
maybe member of congress because i don't
know what the rules are for judges in
texas but if they're just appointed
i don't know let me put it this way it's
an open question what's scarier that
this guy is a congressman or that he was
a judge
i would go even further i would say
don't have
the forest managers deal with this just
use that jewish space laser
that marjorie taylor green was talking
about and
you know louie's real mistake is it's
not bureau of land management
that's going to change the orbit you've
got to talk to the department of housing
and urban development that's
really who's going to be able to get
involved and uh
and change that lunar orbit just wacky
and bizarre stuff and this guy is one of
435
uh elected members of congress he has
one of
435 privileged votes
that determine so much about the lives
of everyday americans not a good sign
for the country that's for sure
one of our sponsors is rise the
science-based app that makes it easy to
improve your sleep
and your daily energy and rise uses two
core principles that have emerged from
sleep science
one is sleep debt as an idea of how much
sleep you owe
your body and circadian rhythms
dictating
your energy levels and rise helps you
figure out your sleep needs helps you
track your sleep debt
every morning rise tells you how long
you'll probably be groggy
when your high energy time will be when
you should start winding down for bed to
optimize your sleep
and so you can make science-based
improvements to 16 different sleep
habits to improve your daytime energy
i've been using rise myself on my phone
i started noticing higher quality sleep
in a few nights
and it's allowed me to just better
understand how my energy levels
correspond with my sleep
and i've had a really great experience
with it my audience can try rise
for free for an entire week by going to
risescience.com pacman the link is right
underneath this video